Speaker 1: Speaking of Ron DeSantis, this is
a sort of like if the shoe fits type moment,
a Ron DeSantis appointee wore a Ku Klux Klan.
They're calling it a costume. But I think it's
really a uniform. You can't really get that as a
costume and as now resign. This is an interesting
story that it's not like a major shock to many of
us. Huffington Post reports Ron DeSantis Appointee
Resigns After Alleged KKK Photo Surfaces.
The picture reportedly shows Jeffrey Moore
at a Halloween party wearing a Ku Klux Klan hood
and robe. A Florida Republican has left his job
after a photo of him allegedly in a KKK costume
made the rounds online. This is Gadsden County
Commissioner Jeffrey Moore. He's a Republican.
He was hand-picked by Ron DeSantis in July. He
is resigned from the board of commissioners,
per the Tallahassee Democrat. The photo I love
these words reportedly shows Moore at a Halloween
party wearing a KKK hood and robe. And then you
see the image here. And it has not been disputed
that this is Moore and he did resign, after all,
seemingly conceding that indeed it is him in
the picture. Moore is the one white person on
the board with four black commissioners. Oh, boy.
Lives in a county where 55% of the residents are
black, according to U.S. Census data. You know,
one of the things I was wondering is, is there
such a thing as a KKK costume? Like what I mean
by that is when I Googled KKK costume, you know
how on Amazon and from I don't know, target and
Walmart you can get like a honey bee costume. You
can get a, you know, Peter Pan costume. I didn't
find anybody selling KKK costumes. What I found
were listings on eBay for actual bona fide KKK
uniforms. And the idea of a costume seems to make
it more benign than it really is. We just have to
come to terms with reality. These are the types of
people in this political movement. These are the
types of people that are circulating in Florida
Republican politics. And at what point do we say
these are that rare of exceptions? Yes, it's not
predominant. It would be silly and it would be
inaccurate to say the majority of the Republican
Party is KKK members or would be KKK members or
people fantasizing about being in the KKK. No,
of course not. Of course not. But it's also not
that rare. My surprise is that the guy ended up
resigning because very often, you know, the move
in the Trump era is you just doubled down. You
never admit anything. You double down. You say
they're trying to cancel me. It's cancel culture
and all. You know what happened to jokes? What
happened to speech? This is my speech or whatever
else. And you don't apologize and you just stick
with it. And oftentimes it works. Trump did it
and it got him elected president. Many times we
said in 2015, 2016, this has to be the straw that
breaks the camel's back. This has to be the end
of Trump, and then it's not. So the surprise to
me is that this ended up with the resignation.
That's what it is. If you're wondering what this
looks like and whether this is only purportedly
a KKK uniform, we will have the picture on our
Instagram, which you can find at David Pakman
Show. Quick break and we will be right back.